unbelievable finish special game
[Applause]
James Harden ends up with 42.
there's John Howe
a recovering victim
from that terrible Michigan State
shooting spree who is a guest of James
Harden at the game today
Hardin vowed he would be a part of his
recovery and he paid off on that promise
not only by bringing John to the game
here today but giving him his shoes here
in the aftermath and giving him a
riveting moment with that three ball
doors
for to shoot five for 28 in his last two
games and and have a response like this
yes
just absolutely incredible seven times
all NBA ten-time All-Star
he's deep in his career 14th year 33
years old two-time scoring champ come on
man try it trying to advance back to a
Conference Finals
just when people were ready to turn out
the lights on James Harden he turned out
Boston lights Cassidy
to you to put together that type of show
for John and the Sixers fans today I'll
put the work in so it's all about being
aggressive man tonight it was really do
or die you know I mean I had a special
guest in the building uh those days he
just gave me uh good luck he bought me
goodbyes the energy so we did this game
for him hey you may need to invite him
to a couple more games in the playoffs
every game we don't know can you walk me
through that go ahead bucket out of that
it was supposed to be a Drupal handout
for me but they uh Jalen Brown denied me
so I just gave him joelle's face and
Jayla Brown health and Joelle made a
hell of a pass at ABB pass and I I mean
I'll shoot that shot every day so and
they made you guys work for it but now
all tied at two heading back to Boston
what type of confidence is this game and
this win give this team right now huge
confidence huge confidence I feel like
last game we didn't play well
offensively defensively we played
extremely hard but we just didn't get no
shots to fall it was about our spacing
here tonight we did a much better job
with facing the floor different guys
willing to operate and uh and knock down
some shots congrats on the win and I'm
sure make all the difference to put a
smile on John's Pizza
back to you what a moment on so many
different levels and layers
James Harden exercised his postseason
demons once again here tonight with a
supreme
magisterial performance 42 points
eight assists